there's three different types of people
in the world there's the oblivious
where believe it or not they live the
happiest life
but they also ruin most of our Lives the
oblivious
my dad told me the craziest thing I'm 21
years old I'm devouring books we're
sitting there at the kitchen my uncle is
sitting over there watching Kings of
Comedy with D.L Hughley he loved Bernie
Mac
two-year-old two four or six yeah Lord
help me babysit these this
whole thing that he's
he would say put him again
the guy doesn't speak English yeah who
doesn't speak English at all and he's
laughing tears are coming down his eyes
listening to Bernie Mac on repeat I'm
like do you know what he just said no
but it's funny right and my dad points
very Monumental moment in my life he
says look at Albert right there he says
yeah see this book I said yeah
the more of this you read the less happy
you'll be like him